à propos de la météo sans doute n'avons
nous pas oublier david et frederick ces
deux cyclones dont nous avons suivi
d'itinéraire cet été sur la mer des
caraïbes
ces ouragans avaient très durement
frappé les antilles l'île de la
dominique avait été dévasté les îles
françaises de la guadeloupe et de
martinique se relève difficilement de
cette épreuve c'est une enquête réalisée
en guadeloupe par frédéric boulet
les destructions causées par les
cyclones ne sont pratiquement plus
visible ici où les habitations de tôle
et de bois ont été aussitôt reconstruite
et où la terre est si riche que tout
pousse et repousse un lassabe le mans
les bananeraies détruite à 80 % t/t
soigné bien sûr le quota de production
fixé à 110 mille tonnes ne sera pas
atteint mais les rougets qui renaissent
d'être ont coupé se développe très vite
tout devrait rentrer dans l'ordre
angevins et l'aide de secours semblent
suffisantes pour tenir jusque là moins
touchés car moins fragile la canne à
sucre plante la plus cultivée en
guadeloupe poursuit sa croissance
certains champs commence même à flécher
et les canons fleurs se gorgent de sucre
production visage et 90 mille tonnes de
sucre et 95 mille hectolitres d'alcool
pur
autre pilier de l'économie
guadeloupéenne le tourisme des
équipements construits en dur et peut
toucher sont prêts à recevoir les
touristes étrangers métropolitain qui
affluent pour la haute saison
dans ces îles où le jus de fruits frais
coûte moins cher que le jus de fruits en
boîte
pourtant la situation n'est pas bonne
sur tous les plans les habitants de
basse terre la capitale dont le port
détruit est en reconstruction craignent
que le trafic bananier soit transféré à
pointe à pitre entraînant de nombreuses
suppressions d'emploi dans leur ville
car ici peut-être plus qu'ailleurs le
chômage c'est le grand problème
les emplois sont rares dans
l'agriculture et les postes de
fonctionnaires encore plus rares les
jeunes très nombreux 50 % de la
population a moins de 25 ans sont
particulièrement touchés et c'est chez
eux que les sentiments autonomistes se
font sentir le plus pourtant les
guadeloupéens craignent surtout
l'isolément d'une métropole déjà
lointaine mais ils possèdent assez
d'atouts pour que demain soit meilleur
qu'aujourd'hui